hello everyone welcome to project for
awesome 2010 if you aren't familiar with
project for awesome let me clue you in
it's basically where the YouTube
community gets together and uploads
videos on the same day to promote our
favorite charities for my project for
awesome video
I chose charity water charity water is a
nonprofit organization that brings clean
safe drinking water to developing
nations they use 100% of the donations
to build clean water wells for those
that are most in need
we gotta
we cut the power
we take it for granted that anytime
we're thirsty we can just grab a bottle
of water or turn on faucet that isn't
the case for almost a billion people on
this planet probably wondering well what
can I do to help since this is the
project for awesome I started a campaign
to build and awesome well now it only
takes five thousand dollars to build one
well but with that one well it can bring
clean safe drinking water to an entire
community of people everyone check out
my charity water org slash awesome and
let's come together and build at least
one well for a community I look forward
to following this project from start to
finish until our actual well is built so
let's make this happen and thank you
guys so much for being so supportive I
love you
you know water is essential to life
without water there is no life